well as you saw in that report Playa
Comrie and the Green Party decided not
to stand candidates to maximize the Lib
Dems chance of success so let's
introduce our next guest James a caucus
forum to try and work out what impact
that could have when it comes to future
elections thank you very much for being
with us today firstly what do you think
is going to happen in Bracken relation I
think the expectations have to be a
liberal Democrat win and a clear Liberal
Democrat win there's a number of things
why that should be the case first of all
the circumstances under which this
by-election is being held but I think
more fundamentally this is a very
liberal type seat
this is a seat that the Liberal
Democrats hold of the assembly level by
27 points this is a seat that has been
liberal Democrat many times over and
it's also a seat in which in the
European elections the remain parties
got 46 percent of the vote and this
morning a poll came out showing a seat
poll in bracken there shows that the
Liberal Democrats are quite far ahead
it's interesting isn't it because we've
and we've heard mutterings of remain
alliances before it hasn't really got
off the ground why do you think they've
struggled to make it work so far
I think principally the reason is if we
think about two pools of voters leave
voters and remain voters there are many
more parties competing for the remain
votes and party identification amongst
remain voters is still quite strong and
compromises being quite hard for that
reason and they hold all sorts of views
on constitutional issues on economics on
the environment and and I think because
of that compromise has been difficult I
think also at the organizational level
there has been an unwillingness to
compromise so who shares the activists
who stands where these are really
pressing questions that's you could
perhaps solve on a single by-election
but it's really difficult to scale and I
guess it's easy in places like Bracken
where there's a clear front one of the
Lib Dems if it's a little bit more
nuanced than you might find people less
willing to stand down yeah I mean that's
exactly right
in North Wales for example there's a
sequel in his model where the Liberal
Democrats the Greens imply it could all
credibly
put through a canvas and win and it's
currently Labor held the conversations
around those types of seats are going to
be much much more difficult and those
the ones that can make a difference
let's have a look shall we at how many
seats are remaining ions could win this
is some analysis that you've done for
safe which on Sunday about the potential
for romaine parties if they work
together so currently 27 seats in
England and Wales are held by explicitly
Pro remain candidates and you think that
could potentially increase to 66 I think
that's right so that that figure can
change a lot and principally to come up
with this kind of analysis I think what
I've done is look at three look at this
problem through three lenses so the
first is to look at all this 573 seats
and England and Wales and say which I'll
remain leaning as of today so broadly if
you look at the seats where the remain
vote would be 60% or above the second
kind of condition we've looked at is how
far head of conservatives and labour at
the last general election it's very hard
to break through for example if they
have a vote share that say 60% very very
hard to get that and I think the third
condition is to actually look at what's
happened recently in elections and in
the European elections the remain
parties averaged around 36% so broadly I
would look to see where the Alliance is
scoring 40 percent or more and 66 seats
I mean that could really be they could
be kingmakers in hung Parliament's
easily and you think it could even go
higher it could go higher I mean it's
worth noting though that 66 seats is
basically a supercharged Liberal
Democrat Party of 2010 it's not that
radical departure from what was
happening so what would happen for them
to get 103 seats so to get 103 seats
what we do is toggle those conditions so
instead of it perhaps being 60% or more
remain we would take that down to kind
of 57 and a half percent and we would
look at conservative and Labour seats
that instead of being 60% scored there
would be 65 and remain parties we would
put that down to I'm at the highest at
the highest point of your estimates you
think that the remain remain parties
could go all the way up to a hundred and
fifty fourteen well not necessarily win
150 more seats but the kind of that's
the window or the parameters that they
would be look
I mean the thing is Sophie with with
full parties on around 25% it's
incredibly hard to work out what the
window should be what the parameters
should be and they all have to work
together which as we know in politics
it's not easy and I'm interested as well
on some of your research on how this
would impact both the labor and the
conservative parties
so this graph just explained to us
what's happening
absolutely so on the vertical axis what
we have is the degree to which of each
dot is a seat in England and Wales and
on the vertical axis we have the degree
to which that seats the remain parties
in 2019 in the European elections over
underperforms given how systemically
remain the seat is and then on the
horizontal axis we have the Labour Party
vote share of 2017 now this graph it
looks technical but actually the message
is really clear which is that as the
Labour Party does better the remain
party underperforms and as it is worse
the remaining party also performs what
that means principally is that the
Labour Party and the remain cause as it
were we can now statistically prove a
fishing from the same pool of voters so
that's a problem for labour that's a
real problem for the labour on it on a
voting basis and let's have a look at
Conservative Party what is happening
here well there's two two things of note
here this is the same analysis done for
the conservative vote for each seats
first of all the trend is much more
loose so there's no sense that they're
conservatives and they're the kind of
remain cores are immediately fishing
from the same groups of voters and
second of all the relationship is
positive so actually then that proves
that it's not necessarily the case so
just to sum up who is more risk from
Earlham reign Alliance is it labour or
is it the conception oh yeah maybe you
won't like this answer I think actually
both both of the main parties if we can
call them that on a seat basis I would
say actually the Conservatives have a
lot to be worried about which matters
matters because that's the election so
the 66 number 66 remain alliance seats
that they could target in two-thirds of
those were conservative in 2015 I think
these are you know in the southeast it's
kind of this is camera country yeah
Cameron country yeah this is kind of
more metropolitan more urban more
professionals many seats there he won
over the
time in 2010 I think though the really
interesting story here is on a voting
basis or the number of voters I think
it's the Labour Party that's going to
have a problem so I don't think the
remain alliance if it happens is going
to necessarily take as many seats from
the Labour Party but it could collapse
its vote in middle England handing seeds
to the Conservative Party and the
bracelet party interesting stuff thank
you very much for your assent and for
coming the program to explain